ivan stepped he began to
go here the scales here and guy in in berlin
bit and on the bunker
on it and furry file and find is no
intention
international peace will over strength and
freud wear out and rhythm was
on church life and
admitted to enter the address of the passage and  where
could you grow fails next
on you kinsey ukraine safes for the summer
67 democracy and
hand have achieved theirs gave them the last days the
ukrainian story dominates the
information field occupies a central
place in the un security council and
now at the general assembly, with this action,
russia is
moving and distorting, they are
overgrown with a huge number of the most
incredible fables of fakes
involving the media from social networks,
therefore, today I want to
dwell in detail on the causes of the
crisis situation and the possibility of their
consequences, the Russian army does not
threaten civilians in Ukraine, does not
shell a peaceful object in cities
that have come under the control of the
Russian armed forces and these cities
live as usual  operates there
transport works
and, together with the local
administration, maintains order, the
same applies to the Chernobyl nuclear
power plant, which is jointly
patrolled by the Russian armed
forces and the special police of the
Ukrainian police, which is located there, the
Chernobyl nuclear power plant is also functioning
normally in the threat mode now for the
inhabitants of Ukraine they pose Ukrainian